[موسيقى]
تحيه لكم اعزائي المشاهدين بانوراما من
العربيه يقدمها لكم صهيب شراير هذه
مواضيعها
توقعاته حديث بوتين بانهيار الاتحاد
الاوروبي واليورو وحرب الاهليه في
الولايات المتحده هل هي نبوءات قابله
للحدوث مجرد امنيات ام حرب اعلاميه ونفسيه
دخوله 100 جهاز لتشغيل اقمار ستار لينك
التابعه لايلون ماسك في ايران هل تغير
معادله الاحتجاجات في البلاد بين الشعب
والنظام كما غيرت شكل الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه
دعوه شيخ الازهر لتهنئه المسيحيين تلقى
هجوما عنيفا فهل التهنئه مساله دينيه ام
تراحم انساني طبيعي
[موسيقى]
قدم الرئيس الروسي السابق ونائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي بمكه توقعات 10 مستقبليه
لعام 2023 ابرز ما توقعته حليفه الرئيس
ان العالم قد يشهد العمل ارتفاعا في اسعار
النفط والغاز كما تتوقع بشان الولايات
المتحده الدلاح حرب الاهليه فيها وفوز الى
الماسك في انتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه
ويتوقع مدلاب ايضا ان بريطانيا يمكن ان
تعود الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وبعد ذلك
سينهار الاتحاد وسيتم الغاء عمله اليورو
اما عن الحرب الاوكرانيه فلم يقدم اي
توقعات لكنه يتوقع استيلاء هولندا والمجر
على المناطق الغربيه من اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وتابع من واشنطن مع حسين عبد الحسين
الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه
ومن موسكو بسام البني الكاتب السياسي
مرحبا بكم الكريمين ابدا معك ضيفي في
موساد بسام البني هل تنبؤات يعني هي مجرد
تنبؤات على سبيل ربما توقع ما سيحمله
العالم العام الجديد ضمن ربما اااه
[موسيقى]
التنبؤات او توقعات الخاصه بنهايه العام
ام هي ربما حرب نفسيه تستهدف المعسكر
الغربي
اسعد الله مسائك استاذ صهيب ومساء ضيفك
الكريم ومساء مشاهدين قناه العربيه الكرام
في البدء دعني يذكر بالمثل الروسي الذي
يقول انه في كل طرفه جزء من الحقيقه طبعا
تصريحات مدريديه في تصريحات
تعبير ردا على التصريحات الغربيه التي
تتهم وتحول السياسيين الغربيين الى مدونين
لصحه تعبير او بلوجيري يصرحون
برؤوسهم دون اي حسبان فنجد من يصرح ان
روسيا ستنهار ونجد من يصلح ان روسيا ستخسر
الحرب وان الروبر سيصبح 200 روبل الى اخره
من هذه التكهنات التي اطلقها زعماء الغرب
فجاء رد همم بتريديف عليهم على طريقتهم
بهذه التكهنات ولكن انا باعتقادي الشخصي
انا ليس بعيدا عن الحقيقه لانه هناك فعلا
مشاكل تشهد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهناك مشاكل لشراء الاتحاد الاو وانقسامات
في الاتحاد الاوروبي نفسه حول العقوبات
التي يتم اتخاذها ضد روسيا يعني انا اقيم
تصريحات مدريديف بانها تكهم لا اكثر طيب
استاذ حسين عبد الحسين ما رايك
توقع حرب الاهليه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فوز ايلون ماسك بالرئاسه انهيار
الاتحاد الاوروبي لم يتحدى يعني فيما
يتعلق بالحرب الاوكرانيه تحدث عن جمهوريه
هل هذا ايضا تضعه في اطار التهم ربما كما
قال ضيفي من موسكو ام همم ربما همم هي
رسائل همم وكذلك حرب دعائيه ونفسيه
مساء الخير استاذ صهيب يعني اعتقد انه هذه
كلام والكلام مجاني وكما تفضلت هي مثل
يعني تنبؤات اخر العام التي تبثها بعض
القنوات الاعلاميه من باب التسليه ولكن
القول انه الولايات المتحده اييه ستغرق في
حرب اهليه يعني قول غريب لانه هي لو كانت
ستغرق في حرب اهليه كان الموضوع ممكن قبل
عامين عندما قام انصار ترامب الهجوم على
الكونغرس في محاوله لوقف عمليه الانتقال
الديمقراطي ولكن هذا الموضوع يعني
تخططه الولايات المتحده ولا نقول تخطته
فقط على صعيد تحقيقات
نعم حصلت من قام بذلك الهجوم وانما على
صعيد
الشعب الامريكي الذي اخترع ضد هذا النموذج
كما راينا في الانتخابات النصفيه
فهذا شيء غريب اما اليوم ماسك فهو يعني
يبحث عن مخرج هو يبحث عن مخرج من السياسه
ويبحث عن مخرج من من تويتر يحاول بيع
تويتر يبحث عن مستثمرين واستقال يعني هو
يتراجع لانه الموضوع يؤدي الى خسارات فكل
هذه يعني لا اعرف كيف توصل الى هذه
النتائج السيد
بسام البني هو صحيح ربما اكثر شيء فيها هو
من باب التهامه من نشرها يعني على قناته
على همم تلجرام ولكن هذا لا ينفي ان ما
قاله من فداف هي همم ما تتمناه روسيا في
هذه المرحله ولكن هل تعبر تنبؤات من
الفيديو بشكل ما عن المخططات الروسيه هذا
ما تريده روسيا حقيقه همم تريد ان ينهار
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتريد حرب اهليه في
الولايات المتحده وتريد ان الماسك رئيسا
لامريكا
يعني بكل تاكيد لا اعتقد ان هذه اهداف
روسيا الحقيقيه ولكن دعني انوه
النقودف عندما صرح قال نحن سنقدم تكهناتنا
على طريقتهم ولم يحدد من نحن وكم عددنا
ومن يقصد يعني هو يتكلم بالشكل الغوقائي
بشكل
ليس واضحا واعتقد ان تكهناته هذه ليست الا
عباره عن حرب نفسيه كما ذكرت حضرتك في ظل
الحرب النفسيه التي يلعبها الدو- ال-
الطرفان ضد بعضهم البعض اضيف الى ذلك
اجابه على كما قلت لك التكهنات الغربيه
وعلى التصرفات زعماء الغرب الذين تحولوا
الى مدونين ينشرون السياسه على مدوناتهم
سواء في تويتر او في التليجرام او غيره
هذه الظاهره الغريبه العجيبه التي قد
تاخذنا بالفعل الى حافه الهاويه يعني
مدريده في يصرح بالتصريحاته اننا نحن اقرب
الى حرب نوويه ولكن روسيا لا تريدها بنفس
الوقت نلاحظ ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تصرح اننا لا نريد حلب نوويه
ولكن الطرفان يقتربان اكثر في اكثر من
حافه الهاويه لهذه الحرب التي ستطلع
العالم باجمله لذلك هذه التصريحات هي
عباره عن انذار ان صحه تعبير عن ما يمكن
ان يحدث للعالم اذا ما استمر العالم في
هذا الاتجاه المستصاعد يوما بعد يوم يعني
ان انا يجب الرجوع الى العقل انا همم اقرا
همم تكهنات مدريديف انه يجب العوده الى
العقل والا سنذهب الى الخراب
نعم استاذ حسين عبد الحسين اذا كان الهدف
من تصريحات مدفيدف هو يعني دقن قوس الخطر
او التحذير من تبعات استمرار هذه الحرب في
اوكرانيا ااه فهل يتجاوب المعسكر الغربي
مع هكذا ااا يعني شعارات او تنبؤات حتى
وان كانت من باب المزاحه ومن باب التسليه
همم اعتقد انه المعسكر الغربي يسعى لايقاف
الحرب ولكن لا يسعى لايقاف الحرب حسب
توقيت السيد يعني لا يمكن ان تنتهي الحرب
واشتتاح ومن دون ان يخرج همم ولكن لا شك
انه الغرب يسعى بوقف هذه الحرب يسعى
لمفاوضات بلا شروط للاسف نحن الان نرى ان
هناك شروط من الجهتين الروسيه ولكن لا شك
ان هناك مطالبه يعني طبعا كانت هناك
مطالبات زياره همم الرئيس الى واشنطن كان
مطالب نحن سندعمك للدفاع عن عن الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولكن في نفس الوقت نحن نريد
السعي في التوصل الى سلام بين الطرفين لكن
طبعا اسهل بكثير الواحد انه يطالب بالسلام
من ان يكون هو يعني تحت الصواريخ او ان هو
ينخرط في المعركه يعني لا يمكن اقناع انه
همم وقف الحرب وهو يقول لك انه نحن نتعرض
للصواريخ يوميا وليس لدينا كهرباء
الوضع معقد اكثر ولكن انا اعتقد السياسه
الغربيه تدفع دائما باتجاه السلام وطبعا
هي تدفع دائما عكس التصعيد يعني لا احد
يريد مواجهه نوعيه بين القوتين العظمتين
نعم طيب استاذ بسام البني ااا لو نتحدث
عمليا وفق المؤشرات الموجوده على الارض
ماذا نتوقع في عام 2023 بالنسبه لمسار
الحرب في اوكرانيا حكيه الكثير عن زياره
الرئيس البوتين الى بلاروسيا واا هناك من
يتنبا بان همم
الرئيس لوكاشيكو بيلاروسيا ستدخل الحرب في
العام المقبل 2003 20 همم ماذا نتوقع ما
هي توقعاتك فيما يتعلق بسير الحرب في
اوكرانيا خلال 2023
يعني بالنسبه للكوشينكو لا احد يعرف ستدخل
بلا روسيا الحرب امريكا
هل ستدخل بين روسيا حرب ام لا ولكن انا
اتوقع ان هناك تصعيد كبير عسكري سيقود
ستقوم بروسيا خلال 10 ايام على اقصى تحديث
تقدير من اليوم لان
قوات كيف استهدفت صلاتها من جديد منذ
يومين يعني وروسيا صمتت حتى الان وعندما
تصمت روسيا يعني انها تحضر نفسها لهجوم
اكبر هذا ما لاحظنا اثناء سير العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا اما عن موضوع السلام
ومتحدث عنه السيد من واشنطن يعني كيف
تريدون السلام وانتم من بداتم الحرب في
واشنطن هم من بداوا الحرب في اوكرانيا
ليست روسيا بتصرفاتهم وبتعموتهم عندما
رفضوا الضمانات الامنيه التي طلبتها روسيا
في نهايه عام 2021 اذا كانت امريكا تريد
ايقاف الحرب تستطيع تستطيع ايقافها اليوم
وليس غدا كيف تتصل الوسي وتقول انا جاهز
لمناقشه الضمانات الامنيه التي طلبتيها
بشكل انجاز لان هذه ال- ال- العمليه
العسكريه جاءت من اجل هذه الضمانات وليس
من اجل الحرب مع اوكرانيا صدقني قلت لك ان
سالت اي انسان روسي سواء الرئيس بوتين
والى اخر مواطن في روسيا الاتحاديه هل
تفرح بضربه كيف يقول لك لا ولكن الموضوع
موضوع مبدا الموضوع موضوع سياده الموضوع
موضوع حفظ
الغرب هو الذي بدا هذه الحرب ولكنه سيد
عبد الحسين يعني همم صحيح لماذا لا تعطي
الولايات المتحده والغرب عموما همم روسيا
الضمانات التي تريدها تطمئن مخاوفها
الامنيه التي بدات من اجلها هذه الحرب
وتنتهي هذه الحرب وتنتهي اثارها كذلك
الاقتصاديه التي مسنا في العالم اجمع
لماذا لا تقوم الولايات المتحده بخطوه الى
الامام من اجل تهدئه روسيا من اجل طب
ابنتها وانها هذه الحرب وانتهى
استاذ صهيب المشكله هي ان روسيا لا تعرف
ماذا تريد من هذه الحرب اصلا لو طلعت
الخطاب الروسي لرايته
طلع البدء بالحوار يقول انه هذه الاراضي
عليها الضم يختلف عن عدم دخول اوكرانيا في
اي تحالف اطلسي او غير اطلسي ضم الاراضي
الموضوع والمواضيع الامنيه موضوع اخر
فهناك تصاريح متضاربه اصلا من الجانب
الروسي
همم اليوم صارت صارت بطاريات باسيوط داخل
اوكرانيا وهذا عكس اصلا ما كان يريد
الرئيس ولكن كان هناك ضمانات قدمتها يعني
همم زار موسكو وسناء الخارج لن تدخل
اوكرانيا في التحالف ولكن الحرب لا تدخل
القوات الروسيه للاسف يعني حصل ما حصل
اعتقد انه الان الحرب يعني هي تاخذ حياه
مختلفه عن ما كان مقررا لها من الطرفين
نعم البني اراك تهز براسك روسيا لا تعرف
ماذا تريد من هذه الحرب ماذا تريد روسيا
حقيقه اا من الحرب في اوكرانيا
روسيا تعرف بالضبط ماذا تريد وقد قالت ما
تريد بالضبط لنهايه عام 2021 عندما قالت
ان على امريكا ارجاع الصواريخ التي جاءت
الى شرق اوروبا بعد عام
1997 وتهدد الامن الروسي روسيا قالت ان لا
تريد للناتو ان يتمدد شرقا كما وعدوا
غرباتشوف حينها روسيا قالت انه يجب العوده
الى عام 1997 عدم استحواذ على الاراضي اي
الاراضي
كما قال ضيفه
روسيا همم انها في النهايه قامت بضم اربع
مقاطعه اوكرانيا الم يكن هذا هو هدفها
ايضا ان تستعيد الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الناطقه بالروسيه يعني اليس هذا هو الهدف
الحقيقي لروسيا
شوف شوف
استاذ الكريم لو لم لو لم تتعرف امريكا
لما دخلت روسيا هذه الحرب وكنا حلينا
موضوع مناطق هذه الدبلوماسيه وبقي ضمن
اوكرانيا ولكن الولايات المتحده بعشره هي
من اجبرت روسيا على هذه الحرب وعندما تبدا
الحرب يعني في مثل روسي بقول لك انا
القابليه تاتي في وقت الطعام بدات حرب
ودفعنا الثمن والعقوبات موجوده لماذا لا
تعيد
ضيفه
تقولون انه همم الولايات المتحده
متعالجرفه ومتطر
الرئيس
يعني لماذا لم تستجب الرئيس
الاستاذ استاذ الكريم عن اي ماكرون تتكلم
عن اي ميركل تتكلم اذا كانت ميركل وماكرون
وقبل ماكرون كان الرئيس الفرنسي والرئيس
البولندي ووزراء خارجيهم اعطوا ضمانات
لانكوبيتش في اليوم التالي نكروها
وقاموا بالانقلاب المسلح ضد اوكرانيا
صرحت مؤخرا وصدمت روسيا حين قالت ان
اتفاقيات من كانت فقط من اجل اعطاء الوقت
لاوكرانيا لاعاده التسلح اذا ما كان يستعد
للحرب من كان يريد هذه الحرب هل روسيا
لماذا يفعل بس سؤال اخير اسالني ضيفك
الكريم لماذا لماذا يفعل 300,000 مقاتل من
الناتو انتشار سريع في بولندا هل جاؤوا
للصلاه هناك يعني امجله قضاء اعياد راس
السنه
يعني الاستاذ البني لا يستبعد القرار
الذاتي الاوروبيين وكان الصراع هو وكان
اوروبا هي ملعب والصراع هو بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده واشنطن لا تفكر بهذه
الطريقه وهناك رغبه محليه لهؤلاء الناس هم
يطلبون انه يساعدون روسيا تشتاحنا ساعدونا
ولكن عدى عن ذلك لا اعتقد الولايات
المتحده يعني مهوسه في الدخول مع حروب على
الاراضي ليست اراضيها اصلا ولفائده ليست
واضحه فعليا يعني ما هو التنافس ان كانت
لوهانس في ايدي اوكرانيا
المتحده الامريكيه طيب شكرا جزيلا لكم
الله
شكرا جزيلا لكم الاسمنتها وقتي في هذا
الجزء الحسين البني
[موسيقى]